I'm almost there I'm almost there I'm
almost yeah
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] not again are it's super so lame I
haven't recorded a video I record a
video every day
why god dammit [ __ ] I'm gonna have to
find a game real fast I won't make that
Adsense [ __ ] surely I haven't done the
gameplay in a while
surely there's the game out there just
for me now for [ __ ] sake
I said a real game after four I played
that wait wait a minute wait a minute
what is this gal gun double peas oh wow
this is great
[Music]
this one this one oh I'll play this I
think I'm gonna play this one yeah oh
definitely I'll play this one so there's
a panic but oh what am i doing
nothing nothing mom it switches to an
RPG that's [ __ ] beautiful anyway
while we wait for this game to download
I just want to say thank you for leaving
a like on this video oh [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
I'm gonna mean Asha please stance on
this one hi I'm Renata bliss and I'm
your freestyle dance teacher
[Music]
ah what kind of person are you
I'm a bookworm jock fashionista pervert
pervert 100 percent all right how does
that affect the game who knows who cares
let's play
my name is hadoo ki Howard oh [ __ ] okay
I literally don't care just skip that's
our dishes cute not as curious Marcia
though Nix
what did explain myself it's an RPG and
burn and button it doesn't work damn it
oh I'm on with the music changes
potential love interest
King stop dancing there better be boobs
real [ __ ] fast or else they're not
gonna watch long enough for a mid-roll
come on what's happening
[Music]
is she gonna jump kind of gameis do it
get away sorry sorry I just reflex
oh my god I think it's starting what is
happening what is this oh my god what
happened what happened I want to know
what happened you're awake huh what do I
do ecstasy [ __ ] what I'll just keep
shooting them what am i shooting them
yeah I see how it is ecstasy shots like
a zoom my Japanese people must have the
patience how did they sit through this
much text I don't understand I mean yes
I have ate it clearly have ADHD but this
is different don't see them young that's
just weird I don't know you're ruining
it great now you ruined it now you ruin
it [ __ ] okay so whatever their zoom in
analyse all I analyze a specific and
then what oh my god no no I can't play
this game I can't I can look at her
shoes those are great shoes so her tits
are her weakness what do i do then oh my
go what is happening what am i doing
I'm clicking at her shoe schmutz yeah oh
my god you know I actually come the same
way you know it's just in the heat in a
moment I can't help myself
I got great fingers nope okay well we're
playing now got him got him
I'll let's zoom in on this one all right
we want to shoot there okay got it
we see through their clothing oh my god
I see through the birches I mean I see
that there's the bushes that is the
problem
bushes am i right sorry all right anyone
hiding snipe them I'm quickscoping these
[ __ ] BAM
it's literally it just hit me it's like
one of those arcade shooters it
literally it's like in our case but you
replace the zombies and monsters with
Nate with with Japanese school curse
it's Janie's oh my god we get to check
oh my god what oh my god there's more oh
that one is tiny I don't know what I
feel about that I don't I don't some
weird balance I don't know oh this is
the best happy face oh boy that was a
close one
you just hit em [ __ ] beautiful this
game is the best game this game is my
safe place
this is where I go when bad things
happen I want this game played on my
funeral I'm on a 16 player launch setup
where everyone just plays this game and
thinks about me actually you know what
they can just play the game dinner oh my
god oh my god what's happening I am NOT
recording that's what's happening are
you [ __ ] kidding me
oh my god did you see the sheer panic
all right tits shoot her in the tits I'd
realize how that sounds but okay I
didn't make the game I didn't make the
game damn it why is she running around
in the bathing's you know what never
mind
ha Jesus Christ that actually scare me
oh I got an itchy chasers twins oh my
god hello you shoot him once you look at
their underwear oh my god oh my god
don't show that
so do I kill them or do they just
disappear G rank more like okay I just
want to say I am sorry about this video
I don't even I had to pick a game I just
went with what I had and here we are
that's right I see all your hopes this
game is practically my oh my god I could
unlock in the [ __ ] outfit and I
missed it come on scan where are they
where are they come on headshot headshot
[ __ ] die sorry too far oh my god
teacher sends a shot [ __ ] yeah I think
it might be a little too into this game
at this point god I'm gone I've got a
gun headshot good shot yeah front shot
god damn it I want to play this with
like a giant purple dildo in my hand
don't quote me on that but wouldn't it
be cool sorry
[Music]
was that cool
what's that cool how much was this game
how much did I pay for this I'm just
thirty bucks huh well I think the only
thing the other question is is there a
DLC oh my [ __ ] milk are you telling me
are you telling me I could pay for pants
for the wedding dress costume set oh my
[ __ ] god G so great where is my
wallet I want to know what they're
saying if any one of you speak Japanese
please translate she [ __ ] punch me
Oh God oh my god yes senpai yes please
wait whoa whoa what did I do
oh my god oh my god Oh
whether you like it what do you like oh
she likes it there okay [ __ ] it's hard
come on I can't please you all I'm just
gonna have to focus on one of you
no I'm almost there I'm almost there yes
that's what I'm talking about
that's how we do it Oh [ __ ] exploding
[Music]
Oh Phoenix oh yeah my job I'm on a boss
battle but I haven't I haven't done my
outro yet check out this video it's very
similar to this one if you like this
video you might like like this one hate
it
ok I'm coming uh I mean I'm okay